new year new hair kate middleton is
rocking a new do as she and prince
william stepped out for their first
outing of 2022 the duke and duchess of
cambridge paid a visit to the foundling
museum in london on january 19th where
she debuted a darker and slightly
shorter hairstyle
just a week after her 40th birthday it
seems kate is embracing the change that
comes with entering a new decade with a
stunning dark hair transformation
back on royal duty and looking in great
spirits kate along with her husband
spent the day learning more about the
care sector and those working within the
healthcare system i really hope i can i
can make a difference you know even in
the smallest way
the duchess recently starred in three
portraits for her milestone birthday
where she paid tribute to her late
mother-in-law lady diana by wearing
jewelry that once belonged to the
people's princess according to the
palace the photos were taken in november
at kew gardens and will become part of
the collection of the national portrait
gallery which will reopen in 2023
ahead of the gallery's reopening the
photographs will be part of its coming
home project where portraits of
well-known individuals are sent to
locations that they are closely
associated with
along with these stunning photos of kate
the duchess received a sweet birthday
shout out from the royal family
the official instagram account marked
the occasion with a couple throwback
photos writing quote wishing the duchess
of cambridge a very happy 40th birthday
today it is a milestone birthday it's an
important birthday according to royal
expert katie nichol middleton's birthday
celebrations were likely a little more
low-key this year kate is probably
happier having something a little bit
more low-key she had a big 21st birthday
um but i think that was the last big
birthday that she really really
celebrated as for what the future will
bring well kate's marking a path of her
own one of the great successes of the
duchess of cambridge is that she hasn't
tried to carry on diana's legacy she
hasn't tried to fill those
shoes which are of course impossible to
fill what kate's done and i think what
her greatest success has been is to
carve her own role for herself within
the royal family i mean she inherits the
title the princess of wales no one has
had that title since diana um but i
think where kate has been so clever is
to
create her own
prototype of the princess of wales
through the work that she and william do
putting the spotlight on on those who
don't have a voice she is of course
continuing diana's legacy we are seeing
the work that she's put 10 years into
now coming to fruition and it's work
that really is making a difference
[Music]
you